[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall at the
spectator offices in london today i'm
joined by rahima matmut rahima is the uk
director of the uyghur congress she is
the co-founder and executive director of
the stock uighur genocide organization
as well as being a beautiful singer
activist translator
author writer and um
someone i i consider to be the
embodiment of uyghur um culture and uh
one of the great spokespersons for the
weakest here in europe and in the uk uh
rahima thank you so much for making the
time to speak with me thank you for that
very kind introduction and thank you for
having me
of course um so uh on the 24th of may
adrian zens has
released what has been called the
jinjang police files
now we'll get into that but before
speaking about that i was wondering if
you could maybe explain to listeners or
watchers who
don't know who the weakers are who are
the weakest
well um
are the turkic speaking
people
we
share more
cultural
similar culture and the language
with turkic people the closest
cousins are the uzbeks
and so
i often say that culturally we are far
more closer to istanbul
than beijing
so our language is the turkic
we believe in islam
and
we have our own very distinct new unique
culture
music
and islamic tradition
and so on so it's very we are very
different from the majority and chinese
people in fact there's no
there's no chinese ethnicity that's part
of the uyga makeup it's a separate
ethnicity as well as having a whole
other tradition all together
yes that's exactly i think the problem
here we are very different
uh geographically we always lived in
that nowadays what this
china called xinjiang but we prefer to
call it east turkestan
so it's a
land of turkic people
and so we are geographically in the
eastern side of turkistan
so you can compare the turkic people and
the chinese people or you can compare a
turkish person to a chinese that is
exactly the difference we have with the
chinese people i see so actually i think
it was in mao annexed
jinjang
and the
region was occupied during the qing
dynasty
and
but then we had two very brief
independence
east pakistan republic in
1933
very short-lived than 1944.
the
communists
invasion
or rather
is a collaborative
effort between the
uh
soviet union and the mouse china at that
time the chinese communist party
soon after they declared the
chinese communist party
being the ruler of china and the
so-called xinjiang
was annexed so xinjiang means new
territory or new frontier and although
chinese government often say that
xinjiang has been the unseparable part
of china from
historical time as it goes back to two
three thousand years
but the truth is
it was
called xinjiang only
after the during the qing dynasty it was
occupied military
military occupation
and
they renamed the region called xinjiang
the name itself
means it is a very new territory
that was colonized uh by uh china what's
the significance for uh the the
weakers and uh
about this uh report from uh agent zens
well since the
chinese communist government occupation
in 1949 disaster never stopped one
massacre after another
uh since the rightist movement
started 1958 and then cultural
revolution
brief freedom we had
in the 80s
than from early 90s again the crackdown
one crackdown after another
so we suffered a discrimination and
crackdowns
over decades
but
i have never
expected the situation become this
one of horror
so for uers
life became one of horror since 2016.
after
chiang jiang guo
the party secretary who ruled tibet for
five years
terrorizing tibetans
then
he was appointed to
party secretary in august
2016. and they were already developing
to
completely
transform
the east turkestan
into one of the biggest police state so
experimenting their
latest technology high-tech surveillance
and
genocidal policies
so
adrian census report
it just reconfirmed
um
what has been happening and i know those
photos were taken during 2017 and 2018
they that was a period when the mass
arrests started
and you can see from the photos
that terrorified
people
young and old
um
i mean since
i saw the report and
looking through those photos
it
it's difficult to hold back
my tears
and especially
i
lost contact with my entire family
my relatives my friends
uh since early 2017.
and the last time i spoke to
my brother my eldest brother was on the
3rd of january 2017.
after two months i couldn't get hold of
anyone
and when i asked him after he picked up
the phone i said when no one is
answering my phone call
he said they did the right thing please
leave us in god's hands we leave you in
god's hand too
and that's my last conversation the the
conversation lasted only like two
minutes after he picked up that one
and i'm not the only one
majority of euros
regardless they are activists or not
they received very similar messages
from their parents
from their siblings said
please don't call us we will reach out
to you when things get better
and
having experienced a lot of crackdown
even when i was there
i left my country in 2000
i you always
there will normally a period of like one
month two months sometimes three months
they'll crack down and then it get back
to normal
and i didn't think this would last this
long it's five and a half years
since
since i spoke to my brother and
um
since i came to this country in
september 2000 and now i went back
because i decided to
speak up and
to tell the
story about my people
and the invasion
also
this
especially the whole jamaica that i was
in guljah in my hometown in
uh february to
in february
1997
and that is event that
that was an event
which i decided
to leave
so you said earlier the things were
escalating through the 90s after a
period of peace in the 80s and then
watched this event in 1997
um from the end of 1996
religious crackdown
started in holga
so
police raided
mosques
and people's homes after tip-off
to arrest mainly young
religious clerics
and
just like all islamic
community
muslim community
anyone who has good knowledge in islam
they become kind of center of the
community
so
after the cultural revolution after the
religion was banned up until mao died in
1976
then
from 1978
the new leadership declared that
religious freedom will be restored
because that is under the
chinese constitution
so there was a revival of religion
culture everything
so um
during 80s we did have really great like
novels
historians wrote historical novels
and uh um also revival of religion a lot
of words went abroad
to study
religion because for that twenty thirty
years period it was banned so basically
you didn't have the the uh didn't have
the opportunity to learn to study
religion um
unlike my family because my father was
very religious so he taught
very kind of secretly
uh but most of the families didn't have
that kind of
opportunities so
in early 90s the
chinese government suddenly
um
realized or suddenly decided that
um you know having this kind of revival
of religion and culture is a threat
to
their power
so the crackdown started from early 90s
then 1997 was a
a kind of um
really
i can say this was a one of the biggest
um massacre
that happened in the history of olga
city
olga where i come from this
so after two months of crackdown
uh hundreds of uh religious clerics and
mostly very successful businessmen many
of these religious um scholars or
clerics they are quite successful in
their own
career as well or either their business
people or
um
have different kind of a career which
people look up to
so
they obviously attract
the crowd so anyone who could attract
the crowd who could
gather more people that was considered
to be the you know
organizer of illegal gatherings or
illegal islamic
activities
so after hundreds of
these
young clerics who were arrested
our youth
decided to protest against this uh
arbitrary detention
so on the 5th of
february
1997
we were mainly young male
uh from
various different villages and towns
um
came to hold a city
the initial figure it was about initial
number was about 200
and then um
other oils
joined who didn't plan on anything after
seeing their slogans
and he said
religion is not a crime practicing
religion is not a crime
practicing maeshrap is not a crime is
another cultural
um century all the
cultural tradition was also banned at
that time so um
that practicing or
mesh rep gathering is not a crime
release
our religious leaders
and
then this
protest
the number of people became thousands
including some school children
also joined
people after closing their shop they
joined as well
in initially
the police
allowed the p the the march they didn't
do anything but
we know later they had already
know this is going to happen they
prepared well well prepared so after
they came to the town hall to uh
you know um
when
all the euros
um
assembled at this one place they
deployed the military from neighboring
county called boyandai
and encircled the protesters and opened
fire
we believe over 100 died
and then followed by mass arrest
uh four to five thousand
in fact the
the real number of you know the
protesters not even that many
but they wrongfully arrested
a lot of uh youth
uh some streets you hardly can see any
young male left
and that was the whole ja massacre it
was a turning point
um and as a one of the really kind of
horrible
scene that i have seen
since the german
massacre
it was just terrorizing
police raided houses coming at night to
search if there anyone uh who looked uh
like the person in in
in the photos they had
and then later after i came here in
2000 then the 2009 july 5th
massacre happened in urumqi
and
from the youtube videos and other
eyewitness accounts
i could relate that to the whole
massacre it was very very similar
so
there's a couple of significant bits i
want to ask you about how you
left because actually that must be quite
a story um seeing as i imagine it's near
impossible now to leave the area but the
significance of this 1997 date is that
the ccp narrative
is that
uh they are reacting to what they
consider islamic extremism in fact they
they for a while denied that there were
any camps and that that slowly changed
and now they're saying they're reacting
to islamic extremism and they'll cite
that there's four to five thousand oils
who signed up for isis that there are uh
this uh i'll get the pronunciation
was uh in 2009 and that they will say
that around 200 han chinese were killed
they'll say in 2013
uh we roll family drove
a car into tiananmen square killing two
and then what is supposedly the chinese
911 was in 2014
uh there was uh the railway attack at
the station uh where 31 were killed by
um
extremists and so um
in what context should i understand the
extremist side of
the
um so when you uh just mentioned about
isis for example
um we know there are a number of urs
joined them but it's extremely difficult
to explain how these people ended up
you know all the way from
some villages
uh then in
turkey or in syria yeah when you cannot
travel from village to village freely
yeah
so what is that how would they have got
there it's trafficking human trafficking
is it because when you are in a kind of
really desperate situation like how
women ended up being you know trafficked
for sex or other things not knowingly
this is exactly how it
happened to other people when you feel
when you are in danger when you know
that you cannot practice religion
you are
at risk of being arrested and put in
camps or in prison
you seek opportunity to leave the
country and that there are people out
there also
trying to use this situation against
them to make money
so many people sold their houses
all the savings and
paying the
uh these traffickers that you human
traffickers
and then they ended up in wrong places
not knowingly so this this is a kind of
situation and also
about the uramji uh 2009
we call it massacre they say unrest or
the protests started also very peaceful
led by the xinjiang university students
after
uh some videos appeared in uh on uku
similar uh like youtube
that the chinese um people killing
two
factory workers in xiaoguan city in
guangdong province
um
of that was really kind of brutal when
you when you watch the way how they
killed them and then they posted on you
on yoko
so the
university students first petitioned
that um
provincial government to
hold those who killed these two factory
workers accountable but they didn't
receive any reply
then on the fifth of july uh so they
were led by the by the university
students than many others who are very
angry about what happened after seeing
this video footage
and so demanded uh it was also very
peaceful protest demanded the government
to
uh answer the question about how they're
going to
deal with
these killings and whether those chinese
who killed this
will be tried hold accountable
instead of
meeting the protesters the leaders
again they deployed military and police
opened fire
many died so the chinese version of 200
died it's their version of reporting
they never report
how many people
they killed
so because of this peaceful protest
turned into riot be it's not because the
ours wanted this to be riot
because this
really unfair treatment
um against the peaceful protesters then
led some errors just
so outraged after seeing this
mass arrest dragging workers onto trucks
and they disappeared all the all this we
know
uh since
2009 that july 5th
um protests
happened
thousands missing up until now we don't
know what happened to the to those
people
and a very small minority of uers
and they just decided to revenge
and
that's how it happened
the the chinese version of they show you
the how they
turned over buses and the killing
killing killing others but you cannot
see any footage of
how they opened fire killing peaceful
protesters
and arresting
thousands and in like going into world
neighborhood
just indiscriminately
arrested and taken away
many
many people this arrest
um lasted up until september
2009
and um so it was also a turning point so
after this
the uh the the chinese version of that
killed 200 majority were chinese
they
implemented the
extrajudicial killing and extrajudicial
arrest policy so police had power to
kill
or arrest anyone they believe they are
suspicious or they
uh
they show some kind of threat
and uh we
so
it was the
extreme turning point
um
also it feels like uh this was a kind of
pre-planned
because we know the you know
the historical um from the history all
these events
in order to completely like crack down
or
make a decision to
to kill or to arrest there has to be
some kind of excuses so this was a very
good excuse for the chinese government
that say that
are potential terrorists look they are
against the chinese settlers in the
region they
using their propaganda instigating
instilling this hatred
also the the chinese people
and the relationship
uh between the uh and the chinese also
became
very very um
intense
and therefore well when you see now
after millions of hours euros interned
you don't really
hear a lot from the wider chinese
population condemning their governments
because through
over the year over so many years
they have kind of
brainwashed their own citizen portraying
ours as backwards as thieves as
terrorists
and so the uh majority chinese people
thinks that others deserve this
so actually it's incorrect to even
understand
these uh terrorist
or extremist events as islamic
terrorists that extremism know that
firstly we don't know the whole story as
you say the chinese are
the ccp are only revealing a certain
amount of the information so we don't
have a real picture of what happened but
also these would be if they are
extremist friends it's the extremist
fringe of a desperate people rather than
muslim extremists rather than a really
it's not a religious movement
i believe so
because i know from the time i you know
uh
1997 after that whole game massacre that
event
you know they just
cracking down on any like peaceful
religious
uh
clerics and the activities
um
it is extremely difficult for me to
imagine that is a space for uh or you
know
can have any kind of extremism to grow
and to to develop when you are under in
such kind of uh watchful eyes all the
time
brother is because of this kind of
unfair treatment under having had
families uh
served in prison or disabled or being
killed
massacred and
all these
really
kind of
implanted hatred
and uh so
sometimes when you are really really
really angry
the things can happen just like you know
when you compare all this to
you know the u.s how people
you know just massacre people you don't
call them terrorists
you know sometimes you relate them to
having some kind of psychological
problem and i believe my people might
have developed those psychological
problems as well
imagine when you don't have anywhere to
complain
to have any kind of
support
comfort
and the state
is the the biggest power against you
and
you know and also all these events none
of none of them were
independently
verified
it's just the chinese version of the
events that
very conveniently to link the oil
population
um
to this kind of terrorism
so in in 1997
you decided to leave
and um i think in britain today i think
there's about 400 euros in the diaspora
so not many people have left or have
been able to leave
uh
how is it that you would it be fair to
say you fled or you escaped or or um was
it that must i'm assuming that was
an uh
staggering journey
well um at that time i didn't have any
other kind of a
record like criminal record or any
record of uh being an activist or
whatever even though i attended a
protest during that 1989 students
uh
democratic movement in beijing but
because of the shia number of of of
people attended that
they couldn't kind of have record of
everyone so i was quite lucky i i didn't
have that record and my file and also um
as being a teacher at
the college
i
although i have been quite active in
kind of promoting the rights
but in a way that was very very discrete
it wasn't like
um
i i wasn't the like target
at the time
um so i managed to apply for passport
what i said was i want to
do master's degree and come come back
to
serve
the college better and i just said i
felt that i need
to
gain more knowledge in the field of
chemistry and because i was teaching
chemistry and english
at the college
and then they agreed the university
agreed
then
it took me about a year to
apply for visa
and so
luckily
um
i
yeah my visa was successful in
my application for visa was successful
in august
um 2000
and i traveled in september
i left my son when he was five we
reunited when he was seven
and uh it's hard
it's it was hard so
whenever i
speak to these
women
a lot of them in turkey who
cut off
from their children
they left behind
some three four children
since 2007
i feel very very sad i cannot imagine a
mother you know
three four young children taken away by
the state and not allowing you to know
where they are the state are taking them
away yeah i have no idea yeah children
separate separation of children
anyone
who
so what happened was after
the parents or one of the parents
taken away to camps
they also took the children away to to
children's camps
chinese governments say that it's a
boarding school they're providing their
best education but it's a kind of
children's transformation school
so that these children grow up
completely
isolated from
their own culture the language
and the religion
so
we know
from the kind of
rough estimate
500 000 but we believe the figure be
very very high because if you have
million or up to three million people
and these two their children they left
behind initially they were allowed to
have other family members to look after
them and then later
they were all sent to
this
centers
and that they are not allowed to go out
from the from school without permission
so it's almost like children's
entitlement camps as well
wow so you can see that uh from the
photos
um
you know that was leaked um
there are children as well
there's a one young young girl she look
maybe
about 10 11
had this pink t-shirt and the jacket is
obviously
someone else's jacket is like
adults jacket
and you can see that the hair was shaved
and
this one one of the
photos he really
upset me
i remember the first the first i'd come
across
and and
heard of what was going on in xinjiang
was the photo or the it was the drone
footage in 2018
of the
shaven headed or shaving heads of
these prisoners with black blindfolds on
uh
sat with their arms behind that folded
behind their backs and cross-legged
outside the train station and it you you
see that and immediately as a european
you immediately think of the death camps
of
the 1940s
and and in fact
it is the largest internment of an
ethnic group
since in the world since
since then um but there is surprisingly
little
footage there's there's there's a lot of
testimonies you know
i've heard some of them even at
the uyga tribunal
which was in november december uh 2021
last year uh um there were some very
moving um
testimonies of what's going on as
accusations of uh
rape of um
organ harvesting
uh it's completely um devastating but
uh
what the information that's coming
through considering the scale in which
it's purported to be going on is is
quite small and i suppose that's why the
zens uh report that's been released
is it's really more evidence of the the
grand scale of things
yeah this kind of horrors
especially
completely
it's especially when it is happening
behind the closed doors
it's more horrible more scary
why the chinese government
ban will speak to their family abroad
why would my brother tell me
would tell me
leave us in god's hands when they often
worried about my health because i
survived cancer in 2013
and they
i kept very close contact with everyone
because they always
worried you know whether cancer would
come back
whether i will feel ill again
um
and then just completely cut off
if
the consequences not that severe they
wouldn't do it
they wouldn't really cut off
um
from me
so so you can imagine you know this
what is happening behind this completely
blocked
from the view the places
just like the holocaust you didn't know
until it was liberated
and we will know
only
the truth
if
the
ccp
regime failed
only when there is a an independent
completely different government or
uh you know organizations
can really
go there have this unfettered access
to
record what what has happened we haven't
even got to speak about your art and
your singing i had the great pleasure of
seeing you perform
at some bartholomew the greats in
november in london and it was an evening
of wiga were music
food art and you performed some
traditional songs and some newer songs
were you brought up singing is uh were
these songs part of your upbringing or
is this something that you've um
appreciated now being away from your
home
you can see my my face changes
whenever we talk about art music
or poetry
you know i completely kind of shift from
this very sad
uh the human rights situation genocide
and whatever i'm in a completely
different planet in a different
world
so
yeah music is uh is
for me it's
escape from this
really horrible situation always been
um i
was very very lucky born into a family
of musicians so my mother's side from my
great-grandfather's
they were quite known musicians in uh
rolja
and
so
from the time that i i
remember
was my mother's beautiful singing
from lullaby to the
other folk songs
and my mom had very beautiful voice and
she played duta as well what's a duty
is a two string
do is two and third is is a persian
so this kind of simple instrument that a
lot like a women play a lot and uh for
we good people when you
i don't know now but um when the time i
grow up
where whenever you go to
anyone's uh home you have like a dutch
han on the wall
just even if they didn't know how to
play
is just like if you have a musician come
to the house at least you have the
guitar that you can you can offer them
to play to to play so in my uh uh at my
uh family home uh we had utah tambor and
the violin what's a tambourine
tambor is a is a another string
instrument and it's far more complicated
a bit like a sars and
so it cramber is a very much
um
no tamper is like a a
most important one of the most important
instruments for the golja folk songs so
you see it humble a lot in holja where i
come from and the rhubarb
uh the one that i play like this is a ex
it's a similar string instrument but
sounds slightly different the rhubarb
sounds like a banjo right now yeah
yeah rhubarb is ver is common in the
southern
part of east turkestan okay and the
tambor is very common in the northern
part of of east turkestan because the
folk songs
the ranges are very different like a
scottish folk song and when you hear the
irish folk song very different
so the the
golden folk song kashgar folk songs
kucha folk song turpa very very
different because of
its own
different style
although all you know uh uyghur but very
different style
so i um
i i always say that i was very lucky
lucky person to be born in this very
large also religious i uh you know my
father
as a
very religious and she read
you know his recitation of quran
was
something that i cannot compare anywhere
maybe because he you know though
as a child
the first time i heard from him
so um so we all often woke up in the
morning from his recitation of quran
would be a song
yeah quran you know that
i don't know if you if you uh ever
listened to like a uh imams or the paris
recite
uh quran is is very much like a song
it's absolutely
beautiful and the recitation of of quran
then during the day listening my mother
while doing housework just
quietly singing
and then whenever we had
any family gatherings or even like if my
uncle's family came to
visit my mom my my family and my both my
two uncles they were really great
musicians and singers there will be like
three four people
would be one would be playing dota
another playing tambour and another
uh playing violin and then that would be
singing
so like in summer
we they would like a
play
under the uh wine
and
then we will have like neighbors would
just sit
on the wall
i want to listen and then my mom would
say just come in come in you know you
don't have to sit over there you can
come and then it we just become like a
big party so i grew up in that uh that
kind of environment uh we lived in the
village
until i was 10. so there was a beautiful
village life we had a very big
house
apple orchards
and a lot of this kind of musical
uh spontaneous kind of musical events
happened
at home or in orchards on this kind of
open spaces
i grew up just following them following
my brothers and singing and i remember
when i was little
my brother's friends when they passed
the street they often came and said
reima rahima
please please sing us a song
and i'd say no and then they would say
i'm gonna give you a sweet you know
kind of ride me and i would just stand
there and sing and check to get the
sweet
well uh
we now have video of one of the songs
from st bartholomew the great um it's a
song called taran now terim or the terim
network is the name of your son zaff's
organization and that's become a friend
of mine and actually i was just reminded
before this interview that zaf and i
went to a comedy show in london
by our engineer sam holmes here
and uh it was at the it was angel comedy
club i think and um he's a very
courageous guy because at one point in
the set
sam uh called out to the crowd he said
are there any right wingers here
and your son zaff
put his hand up and went worried he's
the only one in the room now to admit
to myth being conservative or right wing
in in a comet in comedy circles is
borderline suicidal so
he showed real courage there and he's
certainly a man who doesn't give a you
know doesn't he doesn't care he's he's
um very impressive guy and he has this
charity
um
taram network which supports uh
uh
promoting uh or keeping uyga culture
alive uh for you so i encourage
listeners to go check them out but um uh
maybe you can tell us about this song uh
uh terrain um uh
that we're about to listen to
okay thank you um
taran we have taran basin
in the south
and the taram river
so tarum um the river we always got is a
cradle of the
oil civilization so it's a very
important
um
part
of
the
uh oh your land the easter turkistan
tradum also associated
with the
one of the most notorious
labor camps
that was set up during the cultural
revolution it still exists still have
prisoners there and all the forced labor
picking continent is still ongoing
so um
the song taran is
was written
um during the cultural revolution
when
people
were
arrested just like now were arrested in
masses
and taken to taram labor camp
so the son says that i am going to taram
and a farewell to all my loved ones
all
that we grow up together
and if you come to taran
i will
embroid you
with flowers
taram is a desert
they that you know the harm labor camp
where they are you know
these
oils were taken
at that time
um it's not the place where you can have
flowers or
but it's a kind of symbolic it's
a way to in a metaphor
to
stay
positive
so even in a desert even
if i am in
the camp in the labor times
i will still make sure if you visit me
and i will embroider you with flowers
and when you listen to the song you can
you feel like sometimes we want to cry
because it really
shows that emotion that pain
and also is a song that
is really suitable to sing in this kind
of open field
and so when i sing taran
strangely when i close my eyes i see
those
cotton fields
like you cannot see the end
and the desert and then these
thank you so much for your time and for
sharing um it's just been very moving
and fascinating thank you my pleasure
thank you for having me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
again
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
you